baby let me tell you this look since
being on RuPaul's Drag Race I've been
making it my deal to elevate my looks so
now we get new coins coming here honey I
mean I had the best look from the show
but now honey
catch that catch it I want you to know
one thing I may not have the coin then
my big Chuck rhinestones from head to
toe
hit the flow gloves and our rhinestone
we got money we got titties we got it
all
that's what I want you to know about
this look and we are fish because what I
am snatch with my natural a natural lace
front honey
zoom natural natural lace to cause
babies to go back a little bit okay
natural ish beauty and I still do my
eyebrows with a sharpie
pearl how about there and sharpie if you
like to endorse the whole pile we can
make it sense it and I can sell a whole
bunch of sharpies for you honey and
actually sue it if you watching - I
would love to be a plus-sized drag model
bring in the LGBT money honey pal black
last never POW Black History Month power
madam CJ Walker pal the new Monique the
Monique the ring - Richard and I'm about
to pick up the pieces for pow Steve
Harvey interviewed me I won't go to hear
a lot from you
Tyler Perry I can be that my deals
replacement but I could be her new niece
for your movies and more Oprah Winfrey I
get a career I get a career I get a
career find me baby that's what I'm
serving today
[Music]
[Music]